[Music]
it's back baby
the show that reminds me how bad i am
with women and has taught me more than
my eighth grade sex ed class do any
girls wake up horny
morning dude do the do
season two of too hot to handle is a
delightful train wreck that will just
have to tighten us over until
my most anticipated show of 2021 sexy
beasts
could you fall in love with someone
based on personality alone and don't
worry if you haven't seen season one i
have a whole video on that in the
description below
no heavy petting this is literally
[ __ ] or sex
of any kind so come be obstinate with me
as we take a deep dive into the season
and make some real emotional connections
the purpose of this retreat is to help
you gain
deeper and more emotional connections
but before we begin make sure to like
and subscribe seriously only like three
percent of you watch my videos are
subscribed with season one being a hit
the producers had to come up with a
clever way to fool the contestants to be
on the show
because if there's anything you can take
away from this show it's manipulation
always pays off we're on the gorgeous
set of parties in paradise sticked out
with its own fake host
jeff my name is jeff who we see for one
scene and ever again so kind of like
kayla and in true too hot to handle
fashion the contestants are brought in
and given the chance to show
just how ready they are to find deep
meaningful connections my name is emily
and my passion in life is boys i'm the
real life legally blonde
but i'm also illegally horny am i
undeniably sexy
uh yes and undeniably modest the first
two to arrive
are carly i hate roles and i do not
follow them whatever i do what i'm wrong
in melinda i do have limits in the
bedroom do not
pull my hair don't touch my wigs already
got you covered they're quickly
introduced to the first male contestant
of the group
nathan a uk-born cowboy from dallas
who's also a stripper
that's who the law says that you cannot
touch
but i think i see a lot of law breakers
up in this house emily's up next a nun
from london followed by chase a football
player so you're probably wondering oh
what nfl team does he play for
i'm from seattle washington well i play
football in canada
hold up you play in the cfl that's like
saying you're taking your girl out for a
romantic dinner fit for royalty but you
end up going to burger king i'm just
playing chase the dude has his own
youtube channel
and is in the nfl developmental league
right now so show him some love which he
didn't get on the show
then there's killian murphy from peaky
blinders
today this is my [ __ ] wedding day cam
here considers himself a sexy nerd
milady and boy will we get into him then
there's larissa whose boobs try to
distract us from her teeth
and normally i wouldn't body shame it's
not cool but the show is called too hot
to handle so
hopefully you'll grant me some leeway
here next is peter whose claim to fame
is being a huge tick tocker and you
might think oh we must have some great
content over there well eighty percent
of it is him covering himself at liquids
and taking off his pants
he's also part hobbit seriously look at
him next to chase and the girls
the last two contestants are kayla who
has less screen time than the robotic
host
lana and marvin the french man with the
dance moves of a god
i'm a dancer i can do a lot of dance you
know a little bit of doogie and stuff
to dance like this they like you damn
you're
lucky with that handsome smile these
guys believe they're in for a crazy few
weeks of debauchery but lana is soon to
quash their wet dreams
no it's not too hard to handle this
can't be too hard to handle
and with a hundred thousand dollars at
stake which of our contestants will
persevere
find love and take the prize money home
and how much of that money for that
matter for every sexual infraction money
is deducted from the pile this
means no heavy petting handies or even
self-gratification
and by episode 2 there are already seven
violations resulting in
21 thousand dollars being deducted from
the grand total that's right
roughly half of all the violations this
season happen
in this one episode and this can be
attributed to contestants coupling up
these couples include cam and emily
marvin and melinda
and chase and carly
oh my god and i already know chase
stands no chance with carly strolling
into the resort looking like the rock
circa 1994. so the gang is sent on a
workshop to learn about self-restraint
and what better way than with whips and
feathers needless to say it didn't go as
planned it got a bonus so
i must be doing something right i got a
bonus
and with only a few days in some of the
couples give in to temptation
melinda and carly make out with peter to
make their men jealous because nothing
says jealousy like making up with a guy
who does this for a living and poor poor
emily
she's starting to fall in love with cam
a guy who says [ __ ] like this
i keep my word to people sometimes and
sometimes it doesn't mean [ __ ]
sometimes honestly it's not it's not the
best policy it's denies and eyes and i
night you die
or you're caught in the axe oh he's
gonna get in trouble cam
is so wound up by not being able to bone
emily that he has to engage in a vankal
shankle pact now i've searched the
depths of urban dictionary for this but
i can't find a definition any of my uk
friends if this is some sort of slang
please i need to know what this means in
the comments basically cam asks jason
peter to stand guard for him while he um
self-gratifies himself and the genius
way he gets his friends to agree to this
is telling them
it's an investment but this is an
investment yeah this isn't
true if he jerks off now it'll pay
dividends in the future when he's less
horny to hit up emily and i gotta say
the boys do a
great job guarding nathan just took a
massive dump in the bathroom you gotta
wait
five minutes unfortunately the
investment pays off as well as my
gamestop stock as the very next day cam
and emily are invited to the private
suite where they blow five thousand
dollars
this is due to excessive grinding and
self-touching so basically my high
school experience but things are about
to get even more precarious for cam as
two new contestants arrive to shake
things up meet christina from
south africa at first i thought she had
an obama tattoo but it turns out it's
ohana
ohana means family then there's robert
from the uk
who is the quintessential english
gentleman
christina and robert don't know they're
on too hot to handle but when they find
out
we can't have sex when we're in there
[Music]
uh robert these new arrivals cause the
other contestants to get mad jealous
with some hoping the connections they
made can withstand these new temptations
just take a look at my bad chase when
carly goes on a date with robert but
it's cam who comes out the loser in this
scenario as christina tells emily that
cam
instigated a kiss and when emily
confronts kim about this he's like
this it's no wonder lana believes that
contestants aren't making any progress
in their emotional connections so she
instigates
operation wake-up call kicking off two
contestants who haven't developed those
connections or
who she believes aren't here for the
right reasons she ends up booting kayla
and peter in the process
this is no place for a hobbit while the
girls attend a workshop aimed at letting
go of the past the men are
oh i thought this was gonna be like a
toenail cutter that's a circumciser and
then it's time to get the infamous
green light watches if you remember from
season 1 contestants are given these
smart watches which
light up green only if there is a
genuine connection allowing the
contestant to break the rules without
any penalty for a limited amount of time
and considering how some of these men
last only 20 seconds i'm sure this will
be plenty of time eight thousand dollars
for 20 seconds it was probably much less
than that
well emily decides to give cam one final
chance chase tries to see what's going
on with carly until a giant cockroach
lands on his face
at least someone's getting caulk on this
show check out chase's unique pillow
placement strategy here he'll use this
advanced technique
several times throughout the show and
believe me if i had the blue balls like
these guys i'd be using it too
also to the editors on the show you're
doing my man marvin dirty with having
these weird two-second cutaway clips of
him like
when he's looking like silence of the
lambs has pink sparkles in his hair or
looks like he just dumped his entire
face in a vat of mustard
meanwhile things aren't going well for
carly and chase
you don't make me feel confident you
honestly don't you make me feel like i'm
like ugly honestly i deserve better i do
not the best thing you want to be
hearing from your lady and when three
new arrivals make it to the island
chase is like i mean i was bothered by
the whole carly situation
then again tabitha comes along i'm
sitting here like
carly who who's carly carly slide into
my dms there's no one who will treat you
better than a desperate youtuber
so these new arrivals include elle who
gets slightly more screen time than
kayla
tabitha he's huge just how i like it
i believe that when i see it and joey
who's using his
flair as a penis and immediately chase
and tabitha hit things off
nah it's not awful actually
that's nice i like it
around this time we get our biggest
violation of the season
marvin and melinda go all the way
costing a whopping 20 thousand dollars i
haven't heard someone pay that much for
sex since
i'm gonna come now they need to prove to
the others this wasn't a one-time fling
speaking of healthy relationships just
take a look at chase's face when tabitha
crawls into bed naked
he's gotten over carly pretty quick but
if these men are really going to grow
they'll need to master their immaturity
in a brand new workshop
what do you guys think they're learning
down there well i feel like they're
learning about communication hello you
we've had some good times very good
times you know
remember those twins yes the men will
have to chat it out with their
ding-dongs to master their immaturity
i definitely need to talk to my penis
because
we spend the most money here really bad
things but it doesn't end there the men
are tasked with a painting exercise and
i'm thinking that they lost a great
opportunity to unleash their inner
dicasso's
and paint with their tallywhackers the
workshop does have a big breakthrough
marvin realizes his fear of commitment
stems from his childhood and lack of a
father figure
he wants to treat women the way he treat
his mother and not like his deadbeat dad
i want to be the opposite of what my
father absolutely yeah i want to be a
man for my family
for my future wife my future children
this opening up gives him and melinda
one of the most well-earned
green lights of the season on a side
note you might have noticed a lot of the
contestants snapping instead of clapping
i couldn't find a definitive answer to
this either they're recreating the crab
dance or producers told them to snap
instead of clap as it messes up the mics
but if you know the real reason let us
know in the comments with only a few
days left at the retreat
lana clamps down and eliminates two more
contestants
contestants who have shown little to no
growth or meaningful connections
and just as quick as he came robert is
gone along with christina emily goes
all in on cam but just look at how
uninterested he is
wifey felipe
and this is the main drama for the tail
end of the season as cam needs to decide
where his heart lays
he's even tempted into a naked shower by
tabitha which he
denies after about five grueling minutes
if you were a hundred percent into emily
he'd be like
no way tabitha but cam is still holding
on to his old player ways at least he
man's up and later tells emily how he's
conflicted and the producers just had to
have him in a devil outfit with this red
mood lighting meanwhile nathan has a
chat with larissa
basically telling her she's too closed
off emotionally where would he get a
thing like that
this workshop is freaking me out a bit
because i hate emotions and all that
gross boring stuff
this sparks larissa to remove herself
from the show and go back to harvard to
finish her law
degree with only two days left the
couples are given another chance to grow
those connections in a series of
romantic dates
marvin and melinda go in a yacht where
marvin expresses his love to her
and asks her to be his girlfriend he's
gone from flirting with other girls to
make her jealous to
completely infatuated with her in fact
their night in the private suite where
they didn't break any rules
he says was one of the best nights of
his life emily and cam have their
one-on-one which isn't as romantic as
marvin and melinda's partly because
cam doesn't know how to express what
happened in the shower with tabitha
you know she's trying to feel we can
both agree or not
elsewhere no no it was a valiant try cam
but getting past that and the fact
emily's earrings can pick up wi-fi a
mile away
cam expresses his interest in emily and
asks her to be his girlfriend
oh you were speaking tonight and you
said some nice things to me and i got it
for semi and that's weird
what non-sexual emotional sammy yes you
know it's real when you start getting
those emotional semis
with the final day upon us it's now time
to see how the current prize pool of 55k
will be split up but lana has a surprise
unlike last season there will only be
one winner
what would you guys do at 55k if you
want it strip club
yeah joey you aren't winning and as they
viking burial all the traumas and
emotions they've grown out of
lana tells them she has chosen a final
three for the prize pool
and that'll be up to the others to cast
their votes for a winner
bring back jeff no not that one better
yeah
we have a survivor situation on our
hands lena's final three include
carly cam and marvin all three of whom
have shown
some degree of change and when all is
said and done carly gets zero votes cam
three and marvin four and i gotta say i
agree with this decision
marvin showed the greatest change going
from not really caring about melinda to
calling her his queen and wanting her to
come to paris to meet his mom cam and
carly they didn't prove just not to the
extent
marvin did now you might be asking
yourself are these couples still
together
at the time of this writing we don't
have any definitive answers on this as
it seems the cast may not be able to
disclose
any info until a few days or weeks after
the last batch of episodes drop
however we do know couples like cam and
emily and marvin and melinda
often like each other's posts on
instagram so who knows
overall i thought season two was a
downgrade from season one and that might
be partly because season one was just so
fresh i never really knew
how the show was gonna work but it
probably has more to do with the cast
the cast was just better in season one
i still remember harry and francesca but
i doubt in a few months i'll remember
any of the cast here but hey what do i
know the comment section is where we'll
battle it out and where i want to see
what you thought of the season
and carly if you're there my dms are
open thanks everyone for watching
remember to like and subscribe and you
can also follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you